this is the production of Cornell
University
um so yeah I had I was going to get us
my picture scanned I have a picture from
when I was an infant standing in front
of a grad student housing here at my
parents my actually my PhD advisors in
the picture wearing very nice 70s pants
but i forgot to scan it so so alright so
i'm going to talk today about maze and
spaces of the genome so it's nice to
start with pictures of plants and remind
you that i actually do care about plants
i won't have a lot of them in my sides
later on this is just illustrating that
this is probably the last institution i
have to try to convince you that maze
has diverse phenotypes and that there's
lots of phenotypic in genetic diversity
within the species as a geneticist what
I care about is what are the things or
the information that underlies this
heritable variation so that variation is
probably hiding somewhere in the maze
genome and we've had a genome in maize
for a number of years now if we look at
the most recent version the genome so
this is true of many genomes the part
that's genic is pretty small okay and
that genic parsian is probably an
over-representation because i'm
including the introns and some of the
promoter the coding portion of the maze
genome is a small portion of the genome
the vast majority of the maze genome is
intergenic space either classified as
transposon or other and those
transposons are largely long terminal
repeat transposons terminal repeats and
electrons so most of you probably know
what transposons but just a quick
reminder in general they can be put into
classes so you have class one
retrotransposons these usually use an
RNA intermediate for transposition and
are often copying and adding copies
rather than excising the genome DNA
transposons that the major class we
think about are often the TIR elements
but there are also hela cons and other
types refuse a DNA intermediate for
their movement in maze will mostly talk
about LTR elements and TIR there are
lines and signs
there are a number of hela trons both of
those types are harder to find and so
it's not that they aren't important it's
just that they're harder for us to work
with so I'm not going to tell you as
much about them ok ok so these
transposon that are a big part of the
maze genome where are they how is the
genome organized so this is a figure
from jeff bennett sins group from quite
a number of years ago and what it's
doing is it's taking the whole maze
genome and dividing it into one mega
based pieces and showing you how much of
that one mega bases transposon now we
often think of the pericentromeric
region so near the middle of the
chromosomes is having higher transposon
content you can see that they do but
actually the thing I care about more in
this slide it's often telling you if you
look at the scale it only goes down to
fifty percent so even these quote gene
rich arms are still half retro
transposon in the maze you know if we
look at this in a little more detail
look at how these genes and transposons
are arranged I'm use to figures here so
one of these this one is from a paper
from Hugo tuner and this one's from
paper from answering your false keys
group and both of them are showing what
happens if you sequence a couple hundred
kb of a particular region from multiple
haplotypes so on this top one all of
these things and kind of golden colors
here these are jeans ok all the colorful
triangles r transpose ons down here it's
similar everything in black is a gene
everything in other colors is a
transposon so there's two things I want
to point out number one if I take a
particular gene so this gene here tax
7077 it has different transposons and
sort of upstream of it in different
haplotypes and this is relatively common
I can find lots of other examples in
both of them where the type of
transposons inserted near a gene is
different between different varieties
okay so not only are these genes flanked
by transposons but they're often
differing between different haplotypes
the other thing I need to mention now
because people we talked about maze we
talked a lot of diversity and people
often ask me at the end of my talk how
can you even study this because things
are just moving all the time so these
things historically moved there were
bursts of transposition as near as we
can tell there's very low to no movement
ongoing movement of most of these
retrotransposons and current varieties
amazed so even though there's evidence
of extreme instability in the past
things seem to be quite stable now okay
all right so diligent interested in
what's going on in the genome I have two
different snapshots here and in both
cases the things on the bottom the blue
things are genes and these are two
classic examples in maze of distal
regulatory regions so vgt one influences
the expression of this gene to influence
flowering time this is the TV one locus
that was important for domestication
there's a distal regulatory region one
of the things that I'm really interested
in so I personally come from a
perspective that changes in gene
expression patterns and levels is
critical for phenotypic diversity and
yet if we're looking for that intergenic
space which is really heavy with
transposon and mostly put into
heterochromatin amazed how do we find
these regulatory regions how can we use
chromatin and other features to sort
through and find those regions the
ability for me to put those yellow boxes
on here took people many many years of
careful mapping and cloning of those
regions okay okay so things I want to
get at today I'm talking with you and I
should I was going to mention this
earlier if you just want to interrupt me
at any time feel free I don't need to
get to the end if we don't get all the
way through this that's fine I'll just
stop and release you it whenever we're
done okay so first question is what are
the sources of heritable variation so
what information is there what is the
role for epigenetics and chromatin
beyond the genetic variation we go and
second what is it that would drive
variation for gene expression patterns
in particular what what are the sources
of novelty if
say that genes are important for
expression level chains of porn for
controlling traits or responses
environment how is it you gain new
responses to environmental cue I will
spend lots of time in this first one and
I hopefully will get to the second one
so the first thing we're going to talk
about where I spend a fair bit of time
on DNA methylation where it is in the
genome how it varies and how that might
affect function and then we'll talk
about transposons and gene expression
alright so we'll get into the methylome
and I'm going to give you a little bit
more introduction particularly about
methylation and why I'm studying it and
try to convince you it's worth thinking
about so see if I succeed or not so
methylation we often lump it together
with this word epigenetics and people
use this word epigenetics different ways
I was telling Eric last night it's a
it's tough to try to stand in front of
Eric and try to introduce epigenetics to
you because he Plato's about the best
job of that thought pattern so when I
use this word epigenetics I'm talking
about heritable information that it's
not due to DNA sequence changes and we
can think about this in various ways you
can think about this mitotically is
there a change in something that can be
remembered throughout the lifespan of an
organism you can think about this
through across generations in mitotic
memory chromatin modifications things
like DNA methylation and histone
modifications these are words that often
in our mind we almost lump them together
as those our epigenetics i would suggest
some caution in that that linking so in
many cases they are a mechanism of
epigenetic inheritance so if you have a
true example of epigenetic memory often
these types of things are involved not
always but often however these marks
themselves are biochemical marks they
can be influenced by the genotypes so
genetic sequence can influence them they
can be influenced by transient
properties so expressional over the
environment could influence them and
cause a change in these things that is
not heritable in any way okay so
depending on your definition these marks
may or may not fit is being truly
epigenetic
well I ask myself a question sometimes
is why is it that we are so excited
about epigenetics another way of asking
this question is why is it that most
people are convinced if they can get
that word in their titles they'll get
into a better journal so there are a
couple of different reasons I think
people are excited about or think about
epigenetics is being particularly novel
so one of them I think comes back to how
we teach gene expression so I teach
undergraduate genetics and like pretty
much all undergraduate genetics and high
school of genetics we teach people gene
expression by teaching them black ops in
the lac operon if you basically have a
simple mathematical equation if you can
predict the presence of a functional sis
acting sequence an operator and you have
you have or don't have the proper
transacting factors you can predict
whether expression will happen or not I
think that paradigm is served as well it
fits for a lot of things but when people
got to eukaryotes and realize that they
could have the right transcription
factor they could have the rights to
sequences they still don't get
expression they were fascinated why is
it that our math doesn't add up okay and
promet end is part of that answer so
chromatin is critical for regulating
gene expression and it plays an
additional role beyond the normal system
trans factors that view of epigenetics
doesn't require any heritability just
that there is additional factors in
regulating gene expression a second
reason is this idea of that there is
additional information in the epigenome
there's information beyond what we could
capture from snips this is often list
included in this concept of missing
heritability but it could be part of our
missing predictive ability would be
another way to think about it the last
one is this idea that we could have
transmission of acquired characteristics
so this comes back to the whole
Lamarckian idea right and people are
interested in this idea that the
epigenome could be influenced by the
environment or have different rules of
inheritance people are enthused about
this often I think that in a lot of
cases people have been looking for a
mechanism without having a phenotype to
explain
simple well as we talk we'll go into a
little bit of studies we've done looking
for evidence of this I haven't found a
lot myself but it's not to say it
doesn't happen I think most of the what
I'll talk about links more to the second
part so in agriculture if we think about
why we care about epigenetics I would
say that in one sense historically we
didn't need to care so in selection
plant being was done based on a
phenotype it didn't matter what the
underlying cause was we selected four
crates he would capture those traits
with varying efficiency I think that the
bigger issue now is as we're moving
towards genomic selection and we build
models that are partly based on
phenotypic data but also are based on
the assumption that a model one trained
once can apply to other individuals
there's questions of would there be
additional predictive information from
an epigenome that you would not be
captioned with snips so do we get
additional information the other
alternative in the other reason we can
suggest that studying a methylome or an
epigenome is important is the idea that
this type of data would help us find
functionally relevant portions of a
genome so we have a big species like
maize I gave you the examples of distal
regulatory regions can this kind of
information help us to find those okay
so we're going to get into finally I'll
show you DNA methylation actual data so
I'm going to remind you that when we
talk about DNA methylation we're talking
about three different contexts so C
followed by a G and H with any base
other than a G and then a G or two H's
these sites have different molecular
machinery for creating and maintaining
that methylation in each case there's
essentially a self-reinforcing loop so
one of the properties of methylation
that makes it stable is the ability for
cells to remember it after DNA
replication so this ability to remember
comes from these self-reinforcing loops
sometimes involves symmetry across the
DNA strand
involves self-reinforcing loop with the
histone modification other times it is a
more complex pathway methylation we
often think about it being associated
with gene silencing and it certainly can
be methyl a heavily methylated gene
promoters or transcription sites often
our associate silencing or lower
expression of a gene however its
location matters so methylation in the
middle of gene bodies seems to be
tolerated just fine and not influence
expression level very much so to study
and relate those things we need to have
a profile of a methyl and we're doing
this with whole genome bisulfite data we
used to do this with micro arrays so
some of the slides I'll show you have
older data that is less it does not a
context specific information there's a
whole group of people that have done a
lot of work so this is a collaboration
of Matt gone at the Texas Advanced
Computing Center Steve Ike t'en is done
a lot of the things you see as well as
Ching Lee now one thing I want to bring
up is we know a lot about DNA
methylation and how the methylome is
influenced and what its function is
based on a rabbit opsys data grabbed
abscess is a relatively simple genome I
want to highlight here and in the next
slide why that's useful but doesn't give
us quite enough information so here I'm
showing you about a mega base of the
arab adopts asst genome or the maze
genome and i'm just showing you two
types of methylation chg CHH as well as
a histone modification h3k9 so first of
all you'll see that the rabbit opsys has
much higher Jhene density there are tes
but in may is the tea density is much
higher if you look at these two marks
they're very much co-localized in your
rabbit opsys genome in maize we see a
very different pattern virtually the
whole genome has this chg methylation
there are only some little holes and
most of these holes are happening over
the genes okay so we see very different
patterns not like that now this CHH mark
is not necessarily in the same places as
this other mark so
we've learned a number of things from
looking at a rabid opsys they won't all
translate and can show you this is a
recent paper from Bob schmitz's lab I
want to make a couple points here so
number one you can start to look at
properties of the methylome and what
types of bases are methylated across a
lot of different species they have 34
species there are similarities among
them but there are also a number of
differences good thing I'll point out is
so this is just correlating genome size
to some of these properties this one
here is maize so Melissa James have been
looked at for methyl ohms are relatively
small genomes we're still getting that
point part of what happens in a larger
genome ok so in maize one of the ways to
think about methylation the genome is to
divide the genome up in two hundred base
pair regions and ask how much
methylation of each type if you look
what you'll see is that CG and chg over
half of the genome or say the majority
of the gym has over fifty percent
methylation only a small subset of
Regents have very low and really this is
essentially a bimodal you're either high
in methylation or you're low there's
very few regions that have twenty to
forty percent message CHH is a bit
different in most regions of the gym
it's very low there's only a small
numbers that are somewhat higher if we
look at multiple contexts at a time so
we can classify the genome as having all
three types of methylation CG and chg
only CG only being unmethylated
intermediate if you look at the main
genome the vast majority of this genome
has these types of methylation without
CHH the unmethylated portion of genome
is relatively smaller in a rabbit opsys
you see a very different story so the
majority of the arab adopts assume is
unmethylated this orange region that was
predominant amaze is now a very small
portion of genome and how these are laid
out on the chromosomes are quite
different so here I'm taking chromosome
1 from arabidopsis chromosome 14 mates
in arabidopsis you see a very distinct
type of chromatin around
Harry centromeric region in May is
there's a little bit of a bump when you
to the the middle of the chromosome but
in general you see all types of domains
throughout the whole chromosomes okay so
there's not as much segregation to a
portion of a chromosome no just if you
think about this year another way of
thinking about this is that these global
patterns are due to a composite of what
happens in jeans and what happens to
transpose ons so in general jeans have a
valley you drop down have lower
methylation a gene transpose ons go up
there's a peak of methylation the three
different colors of lines here are
showing you see G chg and CHH
methylation and the dashed lines are a
rabbit opsys the solid lines are maze so
in both species you see similar trends
they both have methylation that goes up
there are some differences and we'll get
into some of those in a second one thing
i want to emphasize I'm not going to
tell you all of the details about this
but I'm somewhat lying to you here by
giving you just two methylation profiles
for transposons if you break transpose
ons into different subtypes so class 1
or class 2 and then different
superfamilies within that you'll find
that they don't all have the same
patterns so transposons I shouldn't be
lumping them all together and just
calling them one thing and perhaps the
best way show you just look at these two
families here if we look at CHH
methylation this family clearly has
strong levels of CHH methylation within
those elements of the genome this family
here which is another DNA transposon
family has virtually no enrichment of
CHH methylation okay so one of them
attracts this type one doesn't I think
we're still struggling feel what the
features are they would predict which
type of chromatin they have but want to
just emphasize that not all transposons
are being treated the same now I want to
pick up two interesting differences that
we notice between what the maze profile
look like and the Arab adopts this
profile because they illustrate in some
cases they're helping us to learn what's
going
what some of the functions of
methylation are especially in larger
genomes so number one if you look at CHH
your say CHD the red line it was it's
pretty much flat and virtually absent
throughout the whole gene of an
arabidopsis gene in May is we actually
see a bit of a bump so there's chg in
the middle of maize genes chg
methylation is often considered a fairly
heterochromatic mark so it was somewhat
surprising to see in the middle of a
gene the other thing that was a bit
surprising was that ghh one in green is
considered a mark of de novo or RNA
directed DNA methylation it has this
bump right in front of and behind gene
so it's unclear why promoters would be
targeted for this kind of methylation so
let's look into these two questions in
the next slides so the first question is
actually pretty easy it turns out that
in maize ten percent of all maize genes
have at least one transposon greater
than thousand base pairs somewhere in it
in that gene now almost all the time
it's in an intron sometimes it's the utr
when you get it in so here's a large
intron of a gene here's a transposon in
that intron it has very high levels of
CHD methylation as well okay so
essentially the reason we're seeing that
presence of CHD is because ten percent
of our genes have these methylated
transposon it turns out if i look at the
methylation levels of those transposons
that are in jeans they're just as highly
methylated transposons elsewhere in the
genome okay what's somewhat surprising
or I guess was unexpected initially was
the fact that these don't seem to affect
expression at all genes with these
insert in them if anything they tend to
be higher expressed in other genes in
the same genome and if we look at
allelic variants so one allele has a
transposon insertion that has
heterochromatin one does not we see no
consistent pattern for which of those
two alleles would be more highly
expressed on the other so plants can
tolerate the presence of these
biochemical marks we would call
heterochromatin transcription can
elongate right through those without too
severe a problem now there are some very
interesting studies in arabidopsis
from tetsuji katani that suggests that
the ability to process transcripts
through here is an active process and
their genes required to do this normally
but normally plants have that that
pathway functioning and they can
tolerate these things so our definitions
of heterochromatin you couldn't get
expression don't really fit with this
idea well so that comes back to how you
want to define something's being
heterochromatin if you want the
classical cytological definition just
start standing or light staining you
want so in practice what most people are
doing now is they use a particular
chromatin mark some people like to use
this h3k9 dimethyl mark some people like
you chg and they just say whenever that
mark is there we call it quote
heterochromatin that doesn't necessarily
mean even though then heterochromatin is
less likely to be expressed it doesn't
mean it can't be expressed its not an
exclusive property so I think part of
the problem is we use this word header
chromatid for multiple types of things
and it doesn't entirely fit for all of
them okay so the other question was what
was going on with this CHH methylation
and gene promoters and I want to point
out this was first noted by Jonathan
Kent and Kelly da and when they when
they first said this I thought that does
not seem right and they were very much
correct and I my thoughts of what would
happen we're entirely wrong so kingly
and my group did a number of experiments
to try to ask what was happening with
this peak I'll point out and this one
here the the CHH methylation is on a
different scale from the other two
contexts but she wanted to know what was
happening with this meta plot peak is
this because a subset of genes have a
bunch of CHH methylation or all of them
do was it a broad a couple hundred basis
of peak or what was going on whoops I
pushed the wrong button so one of the
first things that she found was that
about half of all Mays genes have a
region of high CHH methylation their
promoter and the reason that we saw this
so easily and that it hadn't been looked
at in arabidopsis it's not because it
doesn't exist but because
the proportion of genes this is a figure
from that paper looking at 34 different
plant species and in arabidopsis only
about ten percent of genes have one of
these elevated CHH patches in a gene
promoter in maize it's slightly over
fifty percent okay but if you look
across all these species most of them
have some level mazes just on the high
end which made this easier to spot so as
we start to characterize these one of
the first things she looked at was those
genes that have them if we just plot the
each gene here is a line in this plot
and the more yellowed is the higher the
CHH methylation and what she found is
that there can be a region of high CHH
anywhere from right near that
transcriptional start site through a
couple kb away we by definition required
one within 2 kb in this plot but there
tend to be very small regions so it's
not spreading over a large region and
what she what she did then was she took
these little yellow boxes and we instead
of making a plot that's centered on the
start site for the gene you Center the
plot on this region where that
methylation goes up and this is what how
it changes so now we have a very strong
peak so before it was only up to about
ten percent but now it's up to about
thirty percent so if you center on that
region you get a very high CHH and this
is exactly the place where cg and chg
are very high away from the gene and
then drop as they get near the gene now
what controls where this happens it
seems that it's happening at the edge of
the transposon it's closest to that gene
so the CHH methylation is happening over
transposon but only the edge near the
gene this further away edge doesn't get
that property and interestingly this
tends to happen only for genes that are
expressed so it's more likely expressed
genes and silenced genes so while we
normally think of methylation may
associate with reduced expression this
methylation the promoter is actually
more likely if the gene is expressed now
not only does methylation change at this
site when we looked at other chromatin
marks so in grey of chromatin
accessibility so if we
in those jeans up we have more
accessible chromatin right starting at
that point towards the gene h3k9
dimethyl which is usually associated
silencing he drops right at that
position h3k4 tends to go up so this
position here that we're marking with
CHHS how we defined it is a place where
transitions are happening strongly now
there are a couple ways you could think
about what this might be doing so one of
the ways to think about it is that
having this CHH island it's a place that
is helping to maintain the gene activity
because it prevents the silencing and
that the chromatin marks that are in
that transposon from spreading out into
the chance maybe this boundary is there
to make the transposon keep to itself
alternatively another hypothesis is that
the boundary is there not to protect the
gene but to protect the silencing of the
transposon from the activity of the gene
the way we've looked at this is using a
couple mutants that Vicky Chandler's lab
found these are called mop one and mob
three and they both affect components of
the CHH methylation pathway so in
wild-type we had a CHH methylation patch
here it's entirely absent in these
mutants what we see is when it's absent
we actually lose chg and CG methylation
further back into the gene this is
compatible with the idea that the CHH
island is there to keep the activity of
the gene from being able to spread into
the transposon ok so if you have a
genome with lots of transposon near
jeans you can turn those jeans on it's
going to be important you make sure the
transposon stay off it seems that that's
the function of putting this patch of
methylation they're recruiting this
machinery to that region ok so that was
my stories of a where methylation is in
the maze genome and what the patterns
look like for the next chunk of time
we're going to talk about where
variation comes from what impact
variation has on this so if you think
about a particular region of the genome
and this region could be in an express
safe with ver
a low levels of DNA methylation or
highly methylated and silenced there are
lots of different sources of variation
so spontaneous changes could happen
stochastic changes in methylation you
could get genetic changes this could be
changes at that site or elsewhere in the
genome you could do wide crosses or have
polyploids that would influence
methylation there also a number of
induced sources of variation these could
be mutants so in rabbit opsys we have
lots of different mutants that can
completely remove types or subsets of
methylation if you use those as crosses
many of those losses are stable and you
can create a new heritable variant you
can do chemical treatments these work
with varying levels of effectiveness
tissue culture actually is a treatment
or environment depending on you want to
think about it that seems to have a
higher rate of these shifts and there's
also potential for targeted editing
using epi genome editing reagents now
I've left environment and development
off of here but we're going to talk
about those in a second so there are a
lot of questions about how variable a
methylome is and what are the things
that trigger its variation and I want to
talk about a couple these so first of
all this idea that methylation is highly
variable among tissues some of the
initial idea is that methylation is
associated gene expression and therefore
gene expression is changing during
development methylation must be changing
too and that's the main feature I don't
think that's true so here I what I'm
showing you is four different tissues of
b73 and Missouri 17 and they're
clustered by their methylation levels
but you notice is regardless what tissue
came from b73 is much more similar to
other beats made three samples than the
Missouri 17 use to our pretty poor data
or so I they look different I'm not
telling you that there aren't changes in
the methylome during development you can
find a couple here there are nice there
are very clear examples in plant
reproductive tissues and the sperm or
pollen cells
there are nice examples in fruit
ripening where methylation changes can
happen in development however compared
to the level of variation between
genotypes and other things it doesn't
seem like it's a major change that is
occurring during development at least
it's not the primary driver of gene
expression changes during development
there's also this question of what kind
of variation we see following an
environmental stress so if we wanted DNA
methylation to give us this potential
Lamarckian acquired characteristic you
would be asking for plants to be able to
have some environmental stress though
trigger a methyl ation change and the
way we did this experiment is we took
young seedlings we essentially brought
them to a near death experience you
can't see here but this plant is very
unhappy and then we let the plant grow
in in normal conditions and take the
last week's the plant so cells in that
leaf the their progenitor should have
been in a meristem when we did the
treatment so we wanted to ask can we get
mitotic these heritable changes in
methylation we also had a similar
experiment where we are taking tissue
culture samples what I I can basically
say is that we don't see I don't yeah I
took that out so we don't see evidence
that these ones were changing
methylation so I see differences among
individual plants that either were
subject to these stresses or controls
but the number of differences between
two control plants is the same as the
number of difference between a control
any one of the stress plants and there's
nothing in common among plants would do
the same stress okay so we don't see at
least that these stresses we're
triggering changes reproducible changes
in methylation or higher rates tissue
culture is a little bit of an outlier
here we have several hundred regions of
the genome that do seem to be affected
often they're consistently affected in
multiple independent cell lines so
tissue culture clearly is doing
something I'm never sure how to think of
tissue culture is it an environment is
it stress to set up it's a pretty
unusual treatment you would do to a
plant and there is very nice evidence
from
the idea that you can put plants in a to
skulk you get phenotypes so the idea
that phenotypic variation happens from
tissue culture has clearly been shown
and it's heritable and I guess I'll
mention Paul Moe's now so that's the
reason I'm going to talk to people palm
oil's because most palms go through
tissue culture and you get variants that
are coming out and at least some of
those have been shown by the group in
Malaysia and Rob Martinez group to be
epigenetic in origin okay yes that's
fine it's income so we did this he did
nettles did you think if you went back
and then look at it it stood nucleotide
resolution that you buy two different um
so I don't think I would see anything
different for CG and chg methylation
what we've found is that we can pretty
well reproduce many of the patterns for
those types CHH methylation I struggle
with in various ways instead a lower
abundance and the other types if you
remember CHH methylation most of the gym
didn't have it but when it's there it's
it like twenty to forty percent other
studies so Ryan Lister's group and
others have found environmental changes
that were triggered in methylation but
when they look really carefully what
they found was that they happen to be a
jeans they got turned on by it stress
and often the methylation change happen
after the gene got turned on so in other
words the gene would turn on it would
allow methylation it now be targeted to
region when the the gene turned off
again those weren't heritable changes
because if the gene return to its normal
level the methylation went back again so
I don't know that we would find very
many heritable changes and i'll come
back to this later but this idea that
you would have substantial variation
filing environmental stress would
suggest the methylation wouldn't be all
that heritable because if you could pass
through different environments you
should end up at pretty different points
before too long really most methylation
is quite heritable even across
generations so if the environment we're
really so easily messing with things and
i want to back up and say this is methyl
I'm talking on DNA methylation if we
look at some of the histone marks I
think some of those are probably
changing and probably are different in
these plants even at maturity than other
things but I think plants are reserving
DNA methylation for a more stable mark
okay so in terms of sources those who
are looking at environmental
developmental sources of variation I'll
talk about some of the genetic sources
now since I started graduate school
which was a fairly long time ago I've
been trying to do this project which is
to essentially collect mutants that
would affect methylation so we could I
could tell you what the role of DNA
methylation was in plants or
particularly in maize so we have done a
lot of reverse genetics finding
different genes collecting mutant
alleles we have attempted RNAi other
groups like vickie chandler karen
maginnis jay holic and others have been
doing forward genetics to look for
things that affected epigenetic
silencing and they have found things
like the mach mutants and others so
we've collected all these mutants we
have done bisulfite sequencing on a lot
of them and the these two dash bars here
showing you the range of methylation
levels we see in wild-type plants of
different natural variant lions and what
you'll find is none of our mutants do
much here a couple of them knocked down
chg methylation a little bit and a
couple of them knocked down CHH but
these are not things to be particularly
excited about right if this were a rabid
opsys erics mutants that he found years
ago would be down there 0 here some of
these gifts okay so we have not been
able to really perturb the methylome
substantially and if I take two pair
logs and I attempt to create a double
mutant I cannot recover that double here
so today is there's no evidence in rice
from several groups tomato as similar
evidence that if you really affect
methylation in most plant genomes you
struggle to get back viable plants so
rabid opsys might be a bit of an outlier
and how easy it has been to recover
really strong loss-of-function mutations
that affect methylation
this is a bit of a problem in terms of
getting conclusive mutants and why for
the rest of the story I'm going to tell
you about natural variation instead okay
so we have natural variation in
methylation I'm showing you two lines
now be 73 are the top three tracks and
w22 at the bottom three and all these
regions in yellow are nice places where
the methylation level of the two lines
varies substantially this kind of so
this is looking at about 4,000 regions
in ninety samples here and I helps me to
kind of real estate some of the things I
just mentioned to you so here's a block
of b73 plants and in this block I have a
number of different developmental
tissues but what you'll notice is this
block looks pretty there and similar to
each other so even though they're from
very different developmental tissues
that wasn't separating them into
different clusters over here this is a
block that's going through tissue
culture there are some differences among
them but they are different from other
samples this block here is a whole bunch
of teosinte accessions they're not
identical to each other and they're not
genetically identical either they're at
from accessions where they're still
there outcrossing so we have lots of
variation but by and large this tree is
can be reconstructed by genetic
relationships as much as anything so we
we don't see massive changes some of
issues and this is if I self I data so
we should be able to see some of those
although this is only CG methylation so
it's not that CHH all right so natural
variation I'm going to tell you about
how much there is what we think about
causes for it how it's inherited and
what the effects are first thing I
should mention is we only get to look at
about thirty percent of the genome so
when we compare two different lines even
though only can be sent a three I get to
look at about fifty five percent of the
genome because the repetitiveness the
highly repetitive transposons I can't
look at very well if I compared to other
inbreds the polymorphism rate on top of
that difference in the the unique this
constraint gets me down to either from
about thirty percent to some genotypes
it's corey
% of regions regions of the genome I can
compare when I look at DMR's I find tens
of thousands of cg or chg and thousands
of CH HP mrs that's those are big
numbers that makes you happy I God
things are changing all over the place
but if we look at this as a percent of
the genome that we can test for CHH
methylation it's really somewhere
between about point oh eight and point
one two percent of the genome that is
changing the majority about ninety-nine
point nine percent of GM isn't changing
Freddie's mark two of these lines and
even for these other types we're only
looking at about point 5 to point eight
percent of the genome so greater than
ninety nine percent is stable and hasn't
changed we now have looked at a larger
panel so about 16 lines in total when
you sum up all of the differences it's
only about five to seven percent in the
context of the genome that has varied
95% has stayed the same so all of these
DMR's we have how are they inherited how
stable are they we've looked at a couple
ways so one way we looked at it was to
take those DMR's and use single
nucleotide polymorphisms nearby to do a
local Association scan this was not G
wasps this is just saying if I take a
region I only look at nearby snips gonna
have a nearby snip in lv with this
chromatin property any answer is almost
exactly fifty percent of time yes there
was a snip that was linked the other
half the time there wasn't now having a
snip it's linked doesn't say that sniff
does it it could be that snip is linked
to a transposon or something else or it
could just be that this is a very stable
change it's been there for a long time
it happens to be an LD with a nearby
snip we also looked at by parental
populations and looked inheritance of
methylation there what I would say is
most of the time the genotype of a
region of the genome will tell you
whether it's methylated or not based on
what was in the parents in other words
if you inherited the allele that had
been methylated before it stayed
methylated very rarely did we see a
disconnect between what we expect
based on the local genotype and that
what we actually observed so these are
words that Eric Richards their concepts
that he came up with a long time ago
that have been exceptionally useful for
how I've thought about at the alleles
and changes the idea here is that if you
have a region of genome that is
expressed and a chromatin change happens
that changes expression and this happens
in the absence of any genetic change
that would be a peer at the allele so
it's purely epigenetic in contrast if
there is some sort of chromatin changer
so I genetic change so it transposon
insertion or structural rearrangement
this could then trigger a change in the
chromatin of the low copy shared
sequence they could either happen all
the time when that sequence change or it
could lead to employees state in this
case you have you can serve a chromatin
find a difference but there's also
probably a genetic contribution to
what's happening here so it's not purely
epigenetic so we took all of those DMR's
and we started asking what's the
evidence that this could happen versus
what's the evidence this might be
happening we can find evidence for both
so it's not entirely satisfying but
we'll start with this one first so the
way we've looked for these types of
things is by taking the fact that maze
is an out crosser but the lines were
looking at have some portions their
genome they're identical by descent so
if we look at regions that genome that
are at least a mega base of size that
essentially have no snips we find at the
rate of DMR's the percent of the GMS
dmrs is shown in red so for those
regions it's about thirty percent to
fifty percent the rate of other portions
of the genome so there's reduced rate of
DMR's when the genome sequence is
similar that region but it's not zero so
we think that they're there but they're
not as common as they are elsewhere in
the genome when we take the other tack
we say let's look for this test this
idea let's ask if transposons are
inserted in one line and not another can
we get a methylation change near
I I'm going to summarize it just with
one picture basically in this picture
the plus or minus is telling you whether
a particular transpose is inserted right
here the haplotypes with that insertion
have high levels of methylation nearby
absolutely so don't so we would call
this a DMR and if we didn't know about
this transposon insertion we wouldn't
know that it was being caused by
something else I think this is due to
transposon now I don't want to I don't
want you to leave thinking all
transposons will do this it turned out
when we looked her family only about a
third of all of the transposon families
had any influence on the chromatin
nearby the other two-thirds of them
don't and we still don't know what makes
those two thirds different from the one
third I said they're different types of
elements there different types of
families it seems like some transposon
to influence neighboring regions others
don't now do these DMR's matter what
kinds of effects do they have i'm going
to show you two different ways of look
at this so the first way we have looking
at this was we took all of those DMR's
and we found 2375 genes that were
located near a DMR we had expression
data on the same tissue so we said how
often when there's a change in
methylation is also a change in
expression in about ten percent of those
cases we have a significant negative
correlation there another 53 with a
positive correlation so that is that if
it's negative the methylated allele is
lower expression okay it's positive the
methylated leo's higher expressed I
don't quite know what to do with that
number so it's certainly true that that
not all of the DMR's are affecting
expression but it's also 277 genes
there's a decent number of genes to be
on or off and that some level of natural
variation there in total this is a
little under one percent of all genes in
the maze genome but one percent of genes
being influenced by epigenetic variation
in the population in this case of about
50 lines that's a substantial number of
alleles that could be influencing traits
the other way we looked at this with
which i think i like better after i've
done a thought about them both for a
while was to start not from the dmrs but
from expression change so if i take all
of the genes and i sort them into being
non differentially expressed being
slightly changed to 25 fold change all
the way to being on off states and then
we look at how often do they have a
methylation change over their promoter
what we find is this is for CG and chg
methylation that only the genes that are
on/off or greater than 10 fold change
have a significantly higher rate of
methylation changes compared to non
differentially expressed genes in other
words if methylation is changing the
type of effect it's going to have our
very severe changes in expression so
this subset that are being affected and
in this case if you look at jeans that
the greater than 10 fold or an on/off
difference it can be as many as twenty
percent of those genes that are
associated with the methylation change
nearby so really I don't think
methylation is doing a lot of the subtle
quantitative changes it's doing more
strong changed expression now this is
looking at jeans that are varying
naturally for methylation and varying
for expression the other interesting
idea about methylation is that there are
things that are invariable there
silenced and that we would refer to
Lisa's cryptic information and different
groups so this is from Bob schmitz's
group they were trying to count genes
that they thought might have been
putative epi alleles and they were
counting them in a number of species so
they estimated there might be about five
and a half thousand in maize we did this
in a different way when we did this we
were using expression data from a lot of
different individuals as well as the
methylation data and i would estimate
that there are about 4,000 potential epi
alleles many of these so what 1500 those
already exists in both states in nature
as near as we can tell so they're
expressed in some lines they are not
expressed in others the rest of them
though about 2,000 of these in the 50
lines we have looked at they are
methylated and silenced in all of them
and so it's there's potential
information there that you could release
that methylation you ain't get some
change in phenotype okay I realize I'm
about out of time so this is the summary
of the methylome part so i think that
there's a lot of potential for using
this to guide functional analysis we
don't see a lot of variation in
development and responds to environment
this is not saying there is ZERO but
it's saying we're not seeing massive
changes and we see a lot of natural
variation and we think this can
contribute to variation for expression
epi alleles now if you will give me like
three or four more minutes I'll go
quickly to another story not this want
to skip the Sun so I want to talk about
te is an expression just for a little
bit because I think this is cool and it
ties into other stuff so sarah anderson
is a postdoc in my lab and she's been
developing pipelines to allow us to
quantify transposon expression often we
don't do this because many of the reads
we care about can actually map multiply
they map to multiple families so what
she finds is if you look across
development and quantify how much of
that the genome can be there how much of
the transcriptome is coming from tes
it's anywhere from about three and five
percent up to almost twenty percent so a
decent amount of transcriptome now it's
not the sixty-five percent of the
transcript of the the transcriptome
which is how much of the genome these
things are accounting for but it's not
zero so often people think of transpose
install being silent they're expressed
their often expressed in dynamic
patterns so there are a bunch of
families all of these ones up here that
are only expressed in pollen they're not
expressed cell service there's a bunch
of families the second group they're
expressed pretty much everywhere but
pollen there are also groups that are
expressed in other particular tissues so
these aren't just noise they have
particular patterns of expression those
patterns can include stress responses so
we have cases where particular stresses
will cause a sing an element turn on or
multiple stresses
why do we care about this so often we
think about transposon tis disrupting
things they land somewhere they break a
gene they break a regulator but
transposon could also bring with them
new information so this idea that
they're helping to shape transcriptional
responses by where they insert this is a
concept from McClintock suggested many
years ago that transposons would act as
controlling elements there are nice days
in a rabid opsys that suggests this
there's some concepts from rice and
tobacco and rice as well in all of those
cases though you have relatively few
numbers of transposons in genome and not
a lot of them are near Giants so we
looked at this in maize Irena a carriage
to this and what we find is basically
there's a twentyfamilies of transposons
that are significantly associated with
whether or not jeans nearby are operated
in response to predict their stresses so
the idea is is that as this transposon
moves it can create a new regulatory
response for a gene with the help of
Michelle Spitzer and Jeff Ross sbarra
what we could show is that if you look
at polymorphisms so the pluses and
minuses tell you whether or not the
transposon is there she alleles with the
transposon insertion you get up
regulated expression response that
stress the alleles without it are not
responding and here's looking at about
25 lines half of them that don't have
say that how the insertion half that
don't have have it so only when you have
this insertion you've gained this
response so it's hard to think of how
from a single base change you would
create these new responses and it's goes
on give you this option that as they
carry their own enhancers and regulatory
information with them as they land in
the gym they could affect nearby genes
so so sorry I went through that one
quick then but i'm trying to get done a
lot of time so we can look at PE
expression there's dynamic expression
tease themselves i think they're
influencing nearby genes and i think i
mentioned peoples we've gone appreciate
funding and all of the wonderful people
I work with so take any questions
in this sort of last story a transpose a
suspect like increase their response
with cheese in response to expression of
genes in response to a stress two-part
question are they typically beneficial
to that stress like for the plant you
know are they stress response genes and
to do that indicate that part of what
methylation could be doing is actually
providing information for where they
should insert where photon cannon cannot
and should not inserted not only their
expression bless you sabrine Saoirse so
let me start with the second one so
first of all I don't think the
methylation is changing with that stress
when that happens now your idea that may
be transposed two more likely to insert
in the regions of the particular
chromatin I think that certainly is true
you see some transposons that really
prefer more open sites for insertion
others seem to prefer to land in
heterochromatin at or chromatid sites
depending how you quantify those for the
first part of the question so there's
multiple answers to number one no I
don't think that they're doing
beneficial things I think that in most
cases if you turn on a gene in response
to the cold stress it probably doesn't
hurt you right there probably not a lot
of genes that turning them on are
detrimental in that case so I don't
think there's a big cost per se so if
this is simply a muta expression
mutagenesis that's happening naturally
every now and then you would have an
insertion that would land that would
give you something beneficial to the
plants and that would then be selected
for over time over long periods of time
you get to the point where you came and
see the transposon the transposon would
be removed by mutation other things but
the enhancer that brought with it would
have been maintained by silk natural
selection right there's a little bit of
a problem with this and that is that if
we do look at go enrichment terms
there's some enrichment for stress
related genes around this but often the
stress related genes were defined by
expression
turns so it's circular logic the fact
that they come on and stress is define
who they are the fact that this land
near them and it's causing them to come
on in response to stress isn't very
helpful so I don't think that the genes
being responsive to this are necessarily
more beneficial I'm like I'm elated to
that a bit better love that the
methylation changes expensive dress they
didn't find a lot of changes where
discuss it looked like it was a pretty
severe stress I'm guessing it was a
short duration I wonder if there's any
reason to think or Nikon decide that
maybe epogen or methylation changes
maybe occurred more for a long term
stresses which would be more beneficial
from evolutionary perspective so we
basically did the stresses I think there
were eight hours once a day for seven
days so we did try to give them repeated
levels of stress but it wasn't it wasn't
that long term I mean the problem is you
have a finite life cycle and so if you
want to we had to think of that the
other thing is I've struggled from a
standpoint of like why would a plant
want to remember so if it's hotter this
year does that mean it'll be hot or next
summer not necessarily the weather
changes is it you know so I'm trying to
think sometimes though what stresses you
want to remember what stresses really it
would be important to hardwire versus
maintaining a response those stress so
i'm not sure that these stresses are
once it would be reproducible your
career is very different chair between
like coming up this for one year versus
many years i just feel it as a good have
measured stressful enough you hate or a
few months okay you probably know that
way that if you're experiencing a stress
long term thank you for the entire
lifetime of a plant well it's so that's
where perennial species might have very
different patterns so a branch of a tree
that is shaded all the time will
probably be shaded next year too so in
cases like that being able to remember
mitotically in that individual might be
different than to the next generation
you mentioned during formation of epi
alleles that section then for wine
crosses and poverty mention so when you
say polyphony hear you talking wyd cross
with a low poly but you're talking they
process at geo duplication yeah so
that's something we haven't looked at in
maize but there have been a number sales
particularly in wheat and other things
looking at some of the original alo
polyploids the auto polyploid there's
some publications out there that found
some changes following auto polyploidy
there aren't as many that I'm aware of
and there is extensive of changes as
people have suggested in some of those a
low poly plate events the overall idea
that we're so in one sense that why
crosses in polyploidy is kind of a
subset of the genetic changes part so in
one sense if there is a small RNA
producing locus that's in one capla type
or one parent and not the other in the
heterozygote it would have the potential
to influence the state on both alleles
so the idea is that you're gaining new
signals off and it's new genetic
information to that process it's not to
say that there isn't enough stress or
shock from the process of formation that
could cause it as well when we looked in
May is the closest we looked at was
doubled haploids and there we didn't see
anything changing in a doubled haploid
so going through that you can think of
it as a stress being a haploid for a
doubling we didn't see that leading to
changes I'm wondering so what's the
matter with it what do you have any idea
about what they're looking mechanism
about the differential reproductive
actually expressed proposal for
regularly in the stress response genes
so I mean is there any indication or
something like that whether there any
physical interaction order that there
any local edition because oh that's so
we looked at different families
sometimes the transposon needs to be
pretty close to the gene couple kb that
there is a certainly a limitation of far
away they could be mechanistically we
haven't looked at what's happening but
what we think is happening is you have a
an enhancer sequence in almost every one
of those cases the transposon itself is
also upregulated by that stress but we
think that the enhancer can act not only
on the promoter of the the transposon
but the enhancer that's contained within
the transposon could also
act on the promoter of the gene so we
think it's acting as a local enhancer we
don't see I events that transcription is
starting in the transposon and reading
through to the gene it doesn't matter
which orientation the transposon is in
relative to the gene so that's why we
think it's acting is the local enhancer
other questions thank you guys this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu